Alright. Up to this point I've been talking
about regression in the context of a scalar
input and continuous output. Sorry. Scalar input and
continuous input. So basically this x variable. But
the truth of the matter is we could actually have vector inputs as well. So what
would might, what might be an example of
where we might want to use a vector input?
>> A couple of things. One if you look at
the housing example, like we said earlier, there are a bunch
of features that we weren't keeping track off.
So we could have added some of those.
>> Great yeah, we could include more input features
and therefore combine more things to get it. But how
would we do that? So let's say for example,
that we have. Two input variables that we think might
be relevant for figuring out housing costs. The size,
which we've been looking at already, But also let's say
the distance to the nearest zoo. We, we think that
that's a really important thing. People like to live close
to the zoo and so.
>> But probably not too close to the zoo.
>> [LAUGH] Possibly not too close to the zoo. But let's let's imagine that
it's like size, something that actually Or
actually, let, let's do it the other way,
let's sort of imagine that, that, that the further away from the zoo, you are,
the better it is. Just like the bigger the size is, the better it is.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So how do we combine these two variables into one
in the context of the kinds of function classes that we've
been talking about?
>> Well, if you think about lines, we can
just generalize the planes and hyper planes. Right so,
in the case of, of a 1 dimensional input.
That 1, 1 dimensional input gets mapped to the cost.
But in the case of 2 dimensional inputs, like
size and distance to the zoo. We have something that's
more like a plane, combining these two things together
in, in the linear fashion to actually predict what the.
Cost is going to be. So right, so these,
this notion of linear functions generalizes, this notion of polynomial
function function generalizes too very, very nicely. All right,
there is another kind of input that's important too, that,
let's think about a slightly different example to help
drive the idea home. So let's imagine we are trying
to predict. Credit score, what are some things that
we might want to use as features to do that.
>> Do you
have a job?
>> I do, actually.
>> [LAUGH] yes.
>> Oh, I am sorry, I am sorry,
I misunderstood. So you are asking, you are saying
one [UNKNOWN] that could be important for predicting someone's
credit score is just to know do they currently
have a job. Right another thing might be
well you, you can ask instead how much money
they actually, how, how much, how many assets they
have. How much money do they have? Credit cards.
>> Great. So, so, right. So things
like, what is the value of the assets that, that they own,
right? So this is a continuous quantity like we've been talking about.
But something like do you have a job, yes or no, is
a discreet quantity. And one of the nice things about these kinds of
regression approaches that we've talking about,
like polynomial regression, is that we
can actually feed in these discrete variables as well. Certainly if they're,
if they're Boolean variables like, do you have a job or not?
It, you can just think of that as being a kind of number
that's just zero or one. No, I don't have a job. Yes, I have
a job. What if it's something like, you know, how many houses do you own?
>> Hmm.
>> That's pretty easy because that's, you could just treat that
as a As a quantity, a scalar type quantity. What about
>> Are you.
>> Type of job.
>> Type of job, I like that. How about hair color?
>> So, yeah, how would we do that? If we,
if we're trying to feed it in to some kind of
regression type algorithm, it needs to be a
number or a vector of numbers, and they can
be discrete. So right. So how do we
encode this as some kind of a numerical value?
>> Well, we could do something ridiculous like actually write
down the RGB value which would make it kind of continuous.
>> Interesting.
>> That seems insane, but you could do that. Or you could just
enumerate them and just assign them values one through six in this case.
Right, 1, 2, 6 or they could be vectors like,
is it red, yes or no? Is it beige, yes or
no? Is it brown, yes or no? Have it be
a vector and actually for different kinds of discreet quantities like
this it can make it different, right? So in particular
if we just gave the numbers. Then it's kind of signalling
to the algorithm that blonde is halfway between brown and black,
which doesn't really make sense. We could reorder these. Actually the
RGB idea doesn't seem so bad to me.
>> [UNKNOWN] of course, you have an interesting question of what's the
real RGB value. It implies that somehow interpreting between them Make sense.
>> That's right, that's right.
>> It also implies an order right. It implies that the
scalar order of RGB is somehow mean something that it's no
different from saying red is one and beige is two. So,
if we multiply it, for example, by a positive coefficient then
the more RGB you have The better or the worse, right?
>> Hmm. Interesting. Though, in fact what I had in
mind here is for RGB, it's three different hair colors.
>> I thought the g stood for green.
>> There's, people don't have green hair, they have gray hair.
>> But I thought the g in RGB stood for
green. Yeah it does usually but I'm making a hair joke.
[LAUGH]
>> Oh oh. I am sorry. I am glad you explained that. You know Michael.
>> No problem sir.
>> I really, I really like the [UNKNOWN] factor idea.
>> Yeah so I think. I think. I imaging that we are going to
return to this issues when we start
actually encoding problems as mission learning problems.
>> I think your right.
>> But I think that's I think
that's said about regression for the time being.
>> I agree.